[Music]
you just tapped into the group chat live
in the bleacher report at presented by
pandora
my name is greg ivory alongside my
co-host natalie bo d what's happening
natalie how are you feeling
greg i'm feeling great i'm in dallas
i'll be linking up with you later i'm
just excited to be back in my home state
shout out to the 979 it's good to be
here
natalie's back on her home soil and i i
like i respect that i like that natalie
i love to be back on my home soil as
well but it is game four let's get down
to the nitty gritty the warriors are up
3-0 and we are in dallas
to watch them get the job done tonight
and you know what i'm so excited that i
decided to take a lucky fan with me our
very own bk
37 check out the moment i surprised him
with the good news
you've been going crazy on the app
you've been going crazy i just want to
say congratulations but unfortunately we
did not select you to go to the game
with this but that is okay because uh
that is that is okay nah i'm just
playing with you bro i'm just playing
with you
you coming to the game what is you
coming to game four on tuesday
i was just
[Laughter]
bro we go we go be lit for game four man
hopefully the warriors just go sweep
these boys and we get to watch it
natalie yes hopefully the warriors
gets the job done we get to watch klay
thompson luca doncic steph curry and
more but as you guys know i'm always
giving away locks giving away custom br
bedding socks shorts jerseys
you name it
but let's get this thing going lately
let's get this show on the road but
before we do that
i gotta get in the comments and give out
a jersey to the people natalie i see uh
tone go for he has brooms he has brooms
uh
yeah sweet tonight that's all we're
talking sweet tonight tone goes forth
shout out to you you are walking away
with the jersey natalie it's game day so
i need to know if everybody is riding
the three by two the question is will
there be two three pointers in the first
three minutes of the game we asked you
on twitter
if the three by two will cash tonight in
the warriors mavericks game and here are
the current results
there they are you guys seen the results
so i need you guys to get in the
comments and tell me if the three by two
is a lock natalie
what are you thinking here
you know greg i might be rocking with
the public tonight i like this play i
think the warriors will come out hungry
for the sweep the mavs want to avoid
getting swept at home and i like getting
this at plus money so i'll ride with the
3x2 tonight
natalie locks in the three by two she is
riding with it uh let me get to these
comments let's see if they are riding
the three by two mike x01 says this is
easy uh
nbbl noah says sweep season yes do you
think it's gonna be a sweep season uh
mkhit93 says of course the three by two
is hidden shout out to everybody i
mentioned you are walking away with br
betting socks but natalie let's talk
major markets money lines against the
spreads and point totals for tonight's
game let's take a look at the odds
natalie talk to me and talk to the
people anything that sticks out to you
greg short and sweet you know i like the
mavericks tonight to prevent the sweep
for the warriors they're playing at home
i'm not saying they're gonna win game
five or come back in this series but
i'll show you how i feel better than i
can tell you i think they're gonna make
it a gentleman suite meaning they're
gonna get one back they might lose in
five but they're gonna claim this one at
home
i know you guys see this
i need broom emojis in the comments
right now broom emojis in the comments
because natalie
it sounds good and i just want to let
you know in front of the people the hat
looks good on you you are rocking that
thing natalie but uh unfortunately
fortunately that it's not going to
transfer to the players on the court of
the the mavericks it really really comes
down to me is is the other guys going to
get involved reggie bullock cleaver uh
brunson
dinwiddie are they going to get involved
i i just don't know i haven't seen
enough to make me think that they are
going to win this game tonight natalie
and the warriors are plus money looking
to get some extra rest before the finals
i'm taking the golden state warriors and
hold on let me show y'all one more time
we're bringing out the broom we are
bringing out the brooms if y'all got the
brooms in the comments i'm giving away
some br betting uh socks i'm in the car
oh natalie they
that's a comment
feel
the comments are filmed with brooms i
got big dog nae bae hood uh shout out to
you you're walking away with some socks
p will 420 shout out to you you're
walking away with some socks uh mike app
says luca just can't compete with the
talent of the warriors i absolutely
agree shout out to everybody that i
mentioned you all are walking away with
some custom br bending socks natalie i
did not expect the comments to be
jumping how they are with the brooms but
the people have spoken the people have
spoken we talked major markets now let's
talk some player props it's time for
lock or not i'm gonna put up a prop and
i need all of you to get in the comments
and tell me if it's a lock or not let's
start with andrew wiggins he scored 27
on sunday
and he scored over 20 points again
tonight it's sitting at plus 186 natalie
talk to me and talk to the people i
think my man andrew wiggins can get it
done tonight
you know i'm a little sad i didn't see
one cowboy hat emoji in the comments i'm
gonna let that one go though we're
taking the hat off and i'll tell you
with wiggins i'm not completely sold
here wiggins has only hit this number
once this series that was in game three
on sunday he's averaging 16 and a half
points per game against the mavericks
and it's not impossible
maybe he's still feeling himself from
absolutely posterizing luca last game
but i would not call this one a lock if
you feel good about it though and you
think wiggins is going to continue to
heat up
plus 186 is a very juicy number to grab
this one at
plus
186 is
a juicy number natalie uh my man andrew
wiggins he plays in spurts he plays in
spurts
he's been bawling he has been bawling
natalie so i think that i'm gonna rock
with andrew wiggins in a close-out game
i see the warriors spreading the ball
around playing team basketball i can see
my man andrew wiggins going out there
and scoring 20 points tonight and i love
love absolutely love the plus 186 value
let me
get to these comments though natalie
because it's time to give away some
shorts and um
eclos
that's under
swaggy k05 says not they are not rocking
with andrew wiggins to score over 20
points shout out to you guys you guys
are walking away with your shorts but we
cannot
not mention this man natalie threw down
40 points last game
luca luca
donches to have over nine rebounds the
broom has just failed but i still picked
it up the warriors are still gonna uh
sweep tonight let's put the broom down
so it does not fall but luca to have
over nine rebounds natalie sitting at
minus 115 talk to me talk to the people
do you think my man luca can get it done
in the last 15 games the warriors have
given up an average of six and a half
rebounds to opposing teams point guards
luca has only hit this number once this
series now if it were not a lose and be
eliminated situation i would not tail
this pick but it is a lose and be
eliminated situation so i like this play
simply because i expect luca to throw
everything that he has at golden state
tonight because his season depends on it
natalie i i agree with you i do think
luca is going to throw everything that
he has at golden state
tonight
but i also think that by him throwing
everything that he has i think he's
going to really focus his game on the
offensive end that's going to tire him
out and i don't know if he's going to be
able to go grab
those rebounds like you mentioned my man
luca isn't grabbing nine rebounds
consistently
he grabbed 11 last game five in game two
seven and game one
it's just not he's just not consistent
enough for me
to just go out there and put my money on
the rebounds but if you guys see
anything with luca point total a man's
gonna ball tonight he's gonna absolutely
ball luca is gonna get his but i am
going to stay away from this rebound let
me hop into the comments though natalie
let me hop into the comments uh
let me see what these what the people
are saying oh mkhit 93 says luke is
gonna have 50 points tonight he's coming
out on fire okay shout out to you mike x
always also says luca is coming out on
fire tonight shout out to everybody that
i mentioned you all are walking away
with uh i'll give you guys some shorts
uh now we have to talk about my man
wardell stephen curry to have over five
three pointers sitting that plus
154 natalie
talk to me
talk to the people do you like this one
my first instinct is to say you know if
i'm a golden state fan why not he's made
at least five in two of the last three
but i really would not call this a lock
but if i am going to gamble here why not
gamble on one of if not the best shooter
of all time around plus 150 like i said
i wouldn't call it a lock but if i was a
warriors fan i really wanted them to
show out i might give this one a second
look
natalie says she's might give it a
second look
i i i i'll give this one a look but i
just simply will not take this one
natalie even as a golden state warriors
fan i i i think i'm going to stay away
from this one i honestly will want more
value for this i know steph hits this
night in night out but just just i don't
know if i will put my money on it plus
154 just isn't enough value for me uh if
this was in the twos plus 200 range
maybe i'll definitely take a look at it
but
plus plus 154 i'm not really into that i
think the waves are going to spread the
ball around today and i think multiple
people are going to have 20 point games
for the warriors and it's going to be a
team win for them but let me get into
these comments because i want to see
what they are talking about
plug one says luca triple double tonight
shout out to you plug one you are
walking away with some shorts and
mike epps back in the back in the
comments he said he's rocking with the
under shout out to you mike f's uh
[Music]
scan ipa scanipa says he's gonna have 50
tonight i think he's talking about steph
steph's going to have 50. shout out to
everybody that i mentioned you guys are
walking away with some shorts natalie
now is the time to build a br betting
custom same game parlay which you can
ride with us on fanduel i need everybody
to get in the comments and tell me if
you are riding with us or against us
which legs are locks
which legs are not let's get right to it
natalie starting off with the man
stephen curry
we're gonna go with
25 points tonight do you think my man
steph curry can go out there and get 25
tonight
so if you're one of those people that's
tailing the last prop for step making
five plus threes then you should feel
good here
but i feel good here just because of his
efficiency in the paint this season i
don't think it will be a problem for him
to get 25 i feel good about this one
enough said if i was a warriors fan
though i would like this even more i'm
not necessarily wanting stuff to go off
but because of that efficiency getting
to the rim and finishing i think he can
easily do this and it doesn't just have
to be dependent on his threes
i don't know but on the other side of
this though greg i think that if we're
gonna see team basketball being played
right we've been talking about that how
the warriors have such a unit it's no
longer the same stars just absolutely
going off doing it all themselves we
have new faces in the fold so i mean
this one does give me a little little
bit more concern but you have to also
think i'm thinking about it from the
mavericks pov i really want them to get
one back but in reality we're talking
about steph curry here okay he's a pure
scorer 25 points should not be a problem
but let's let's look at our second leg
i'm gonna go to that second leg here but
greg if you have any thoughts for me if
you want to say something about the 25 i
know you're with me though because
you're big on the war no yeah i i
definitely think steph curry can't get
the 25 points tonight uh the broom just
fell again and almost knocked over my
computer so
i had to put the broom down but we are
back natalie we're back that might be
signs that might be signs from the broom
gods that you know this is going to get
done tonight we're talking about steph
curry 25 points and then the broom falls
and i don't know the gods are sending a
sign but i think that one is it's a bad
thing let's move on let's move on to
luca donches tonight natalie i i
honestly think this one is a layup i do
think this one is a layup luca dances to
score 30 plus points tonight talk to me
talk to the people do you think he can
get this done
i'm feeling even better since the broom
fell to be honest with you greg but no
in all reality i'm a little scared about
this second leg because i might be too
confident in this
it's almost automatic for luca to score
30 plus in my mind at this point he's
put up a few 40 pieces recently and this
one is to avoid a sweep at home i am all
in on this leg and i'm gonna just go
ahead and say the broom agreed with me
the vibes have turned we're putting away
the brooms we're getting out the hats
here and luca's with us
luca is gonna be out there natalie luca
might get his he's been getting his this
whole season i mean this whole series he
has been getting his this season as well
but this whole series he's been getting
his
so i can see this leg cashing but all
that hat all that uh i don't know if
we're on the same page there natalie but
let's see if we're on the same page
about this next one because andrew
wiggins has been knocking down some big
shots for the warriors in this series
two plus three pointers made do you
think my guy a wiggins can go out there
and go get two three pointers tonight
so what's interesting about wiggins in
this spot is in game three he put up 27
right but he was actually one for five
from beyond the arc but we have seen him
hit this number in two of three games in
this series we know that he can do it so
i think this could definitely happen
especially because he's in that bounce
back spot he was one for five last game
like i mentioned so i think that this
definitely could happen and i'm pretty
confident about this leg
natalie is confident in it i can see it
happening too natalie let's move on
because we got two more three pointers
made but from the other team the other
side jalen brunson can he go out there
and get two threes tonight natalie talk
to me talk to the people
so because i'm hoping for a mavericks
win today and we'll just bring it back
broom's got too much love we'll bring
back the hat
i am automatically bought in here luca
needs a supporting cast this is
blaringly obvious in this series we all
know this and bronson has stepped up i
expect him to do the same tonight i'm a
little bit more worried about other guys
but brunson two plus made threes i think
it's no problem
natalie thinks it's no problem let's put
up the tickets so i can show you guys if
you guys wish to put a hundred dollars
down
you will be walking away with 472.76
natalie liv isn't here today
so you have to do the honors what are
you grading our parlay today
so last time i was here liv mentioned a
certain grade for good vibes and i think
that was a b-minus
so in honor of liv her not being here
today i'm gonna give it that b grade but
i'm gonna go b plus because i really
really like this parlay and i don't know
greg it seems i don't know if that's a
bad sign i'm too confident but b-plus
for me and i could really see it cashing
natalie's locking in the b-plus
we are gonna ride with it send us good
vibes you're sending good vibes our way
but speaking of luca dances we've teamed
up with our friends over at fanduel
they're hooking you guys up with a
special boost for tonight created by the
nba legend himself charles barkley we
got luca donches to score 30 plus points
and have 10 plus rebounds boosted from
plus 125 to plus 200. natalie talk to me
talk to the people what are you thinking
here and are you taken
absolutely i think grabbing this at plus
200 is a steal and here's why he is
averaging 31.5 points per game in the
series and nine rebounds okay so he's
averaging nine he needs to make ten he
can do that there is no better time for
him to him to step up than in an
elimination game at home in the nba
playoffs for the western conference
title i know this he knows this we all
know this and he's a star i think that
he can hit both of these numbers easily
tonight
natalie thinks he can hit it easily
luca will get his but the biggest
question to be answered
in this series and tonight is will the
other mavericks will they get theirs all
right we talked about player props and
major markets for this matchup now i
want to know if you think the warriors
will pull off the sweep tonight natalie
before we get into it let's take a look
at the current odds
going into tonight's game
there they are now natalie i'll be
honest
i'm no fortune teller
but these odds are looking real
real good for my golden state warriors
what do you think will they sweep the
maps or will the mavs keep this series
alive tonight
i am very confident that luca will do
his part but we keep mentioning it
we need to see a few other players step
up in order to make this happen cleburne
bullock were combined 0 for 15 last game
brunson has been doing all he can but
it's those guys klieber bullock that are
part of that supporting cast that will
have to show up if the mavs are gonna
pull it off tonight and get one back and
you know greg i don't think this is that
re unrealistic right we see the
difference this makes and how they can
play it was on display during game seven
in phoenix i mean at one point they were
nearly up 50 but the mavericks need to
come together they need to get some
pride and they need to have other guys
besides luca who get those significant
minutes to show up and show out tonight
because their season depends on it
their season definitely depends on it
natalie but let's just like let's just
be honest this one's over
cause this one's over pack it up mail it
up go to cancun tonight on three one two
three cancun just go go on vacation it's
been a long season uh you know
and go i don't know go go on vacation
the warriors move on let's just wrap
this one up but you guys heard from us
and we want to hear from you what are
your predictions you think the warriors
are taking it all tonight i'm in the
comments and uh i see a lot of brooms a
lot of brooms nbbl noah broome shout out
to you you are walking away with
a hoodie no you walk away with some
socks i also got iowa forever 90
warriors taking it tonight in the
thriller
sweep you are also walking away with
some socks and i got one more natalie
one more ryan ray says
if the golden state warriors doesn't win
i think they want the golden state
lawyers to win so shout out to everybody
i mentioned you are walking away with
some socks natalie we're getting down to
the wire here the finals are right
around the corner and i want to hear who
you think is winning it all let's take a
look at the current odds there they are
natalie
who you got winning it all
greg i know you'll like this answer i'm
really liking the warriors to win the
finals and so is vegas they're the
favorite this is no surprise but i think
they're gonna continue to keep playing
better and better we've got the ogs
meshing well with newer faces like
jordan poole they're playing their best
basketball all season right now and it
is very hard to stop to be honest with
you though am i taking this at 155 minus
155 that is probably not uh even though
i think that's a realistic outcome i
would look elsewhere i think there could
be some value on the celtics that might
be where i sprinkle my money but
realistically i am with the favorite the
golden state warriors have the best
chance it's as simple as that
the golden state warriors do have the
best chance and who do i think is going
to win i i would say the golden state
wares but
i'm a man that likes money natalie i
like my money and and
in this situation i see the
boston celtics
sitting at plus 260 and i know they're
in the battle they are in the battle
against that miami heat team
but if the boston celtics somehow
someway get past the heat team and they
face this golden state warriors team if
you historically look at the matchup in
recent years
the celtics have the warriors number
so plus 260 if i can get it right now
i might throw some money on it i might
throw some money on it but
i do think the golden state wares will
win i just don't like the minus 155
value so with that being said natalie uh
we want to hear from you actually we
want to hear from you the people so get
in the comments and tell me if you
who do you think is winning the nba
finals because i'm in the comments right
now and i'm looking for some takes
a afraid and a friend that says warriors
heat is going to be brazy
uh ryan ray says boston for the ship
maybe
and i got richie 21 says warriors 2022
champs shout out to everybody i
mentioned you are walking away with some
socks
natalie it's time to get on out of here
we got a game to go catch thank you guys
for tapping into the group chat
presented by fanduel remember what you
learned today the 3x2 is a lock the br
betting same game parlay is a lock and
we will be back next thursday giving
away more custom vr vetting socks
jerseys and of course more locks if you
want a prize today we will dm you you
guys already know
we go be at the game i'ma be there
supporting my warriors so make sure you
guys follow along on the br betting
socials alongside natalie bodie i'm greg
ivory and we
are leaving the group chat peace
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you